hi everyone how's it going today we're
gonna take a look behind the scenes of
JavaScript engines and specifically
we're gonna take a look at what that
means for JavaScript developers like you
and I now I work on the v8 team at
Google and v8 is the JavaScript engine
that's used within Google Chrome but
also note yes and some other projects so
let's just initialize this environment
variable right there and update the
slides and there we go yeah so
disclaimer I am going to talk about some
v8 specific internals but I guarantee
that all the performance advice that
will draw from this knowledge applies
not just to v8 and Chrome but to all
browsers and all JavaScript engines
across the board and I think that's
really important so let's get right into
it javascript objects can have arbitrary
properties associated with them the
names of these properties can consist of
alphanumeric characters or even weird
Unicode characters as well but one
specific case that JavaScript engines
can choose to optimize for our
properties whose names are entirely
numeric more specifically array indexes
in v8 array indexes are stored
separately they're treated specially
although in many circumstances these
properties behave just like other
properties v8 chooses to store them
separately from non numeric properties
for optimization purposes internally via
v8 even gives these properties a name
they're called elements so think of it
this way objects have properties and
values and arrays have indexes that map
to elements it's just the names that we
use in v8 now whenever you're running
JavaScript code v8 keeps track of what
kind of elements each array contains
this information allows VA to optimize
any operations on the array specifically
for this type of elements so for example
when you call reduce or map or for each
on an array if yet can use that
information to optimize those calls
now take this array for example what
kind of elements does it contain well if
you were to ask the typeof operator in
JavaScript it will tell you that all
these three elements are numbers at the
JavaScript language
that's all you'll get JavaScript doesn't
distinguish between integers floats and
doubles but behind the scenes in the
JavaScript engine itself we can make
this more precise distinction so the
elements count for this array is packed
my elements and we'll get to the packed
part in a minute so ignore that for now
for now focus on the my part in v8 smile
is a smile refers to the particular
format that we use to store small
integers that's what it stands for small
integer later adding a floating-point
number to the same array transitions the
elements kinds to a more generic version
packed double elements now adding a
string literal to the array changes the
elements kind once again v8 assigns and
elements kind to each array and as we've
seen the elements kind of an array is
not stat in stone it can change at
runtime in this case we transitions all
the way from packets my elements to
packed elements so far we've seen three
distinct elements kinds there's one for
smize doubles and regular elements you
can think of this as a pyramid because
the set of numbers that can be
represented as a smile is a subset of
the numbers that can be represented as a
double and the same thing goes for
doubles versus regular elements but
what's important here is that these
element kind transitions can only occur
in one direction you go from a very
specific one like the ones at the top to
one that is more general like the ones
at the bottom it only goes downwards and
once we transition to packed elements
which is for regular elements we can
never transition upwards again we can
never go back up to packed double
elements for example now going back to
that array that we had before the array
contains five elements what happens if
we assign a value to do the index that
is far outside of the arrays boundaries
for example if we assign a value at
position nine in the array while doing
this creates holes in the array the
holes are at positions five until eight
the array is now sparse or holy as we
call it in v8
so creating holes in the array
downgrades the elements guides to it's a
holy variant in this case we went from
packed elements to holy elements now
there are other ways of creating holes
for example if you use the delete
operator on an indexed element that also
creates a hole or if you have an array
literal and you just forget to assign a
value like for example if you have two
commas and there is no value in between
them that would also create a hole so
why does Fiat care so much about whether
there's a hole in an array or not why
does it care so much that it has a
separate elements kind for holes let's
find out by taking a look at an example
just pretend that you're a JavaScript
engine for the next couple of minutes
okay
and you're getting the element at index
eight what's the value for the element
at index eight that's the question that
we need to answer you can't just give
the answer right away you have to do
some work you have to follow the spec to
get the answer so v8 starts off by doing
a bounced check on the array index is
this index between zero inclusive and
the length of the array exclusive and in
this case the bounds check succeeds but
we still cannot really answer the
question of what the result is more work
is needed so now we look up the property
named eight on the array itself but in
this case that property doesn't exist
because all that's there is a hole so we
still cannot answer the question we have
to take a little deeper now because the
property is not present on the array
itself we have to grow up the prototype
chain until either a value is found or
the prototype chain ends and the first
thing we check in a prototype chain is
array the prototype because that's the
prototype for any array and this does
not have a product this does not have a
property named 8 defined on it so at
this point we still do not know what the
answer is we have to continue to follow
the prototype chain now the next item in
a prototype chain is object or prototype
because that's the prototype of a radar
prototype and we check if the property
eight exists there but it doesn't and in
this case the prototype chain ends after
reaching object dot prototype
it could be even longer in case someone
extended it that is a totally valid
thing to do in JavaScript you can muck
with built-in prototypes and we'd say
it's probably a bad practice but as a
JavaScript engine you have to support
these cases because it can happen in the
real world now in this case because the
chain ends we cannot continue searching
for the property which means we can now
finally answer our question the hole at
position 8 in the array is undefined yay
finally well from a JavaScript engines
perspective that's a lot of work that we
just did just to get an undefined value
right now if you compare that to a
packed array which is an array that is
guaranteed to have no holes in it it
turns out that we don't actually have to
do up a lot of this work if the array
index is within bounds then the
JavaScript engine can already return the
value no other checks or expensive
lookups on the prototype chain are
needed at all now if we go back to a
holy array even if we get a property
that does exist within a holy array
there's still a bit more work that we
have to do we have to check if the
property exists first because we know
there are holes in this array so vhx if
the index is within the bounds of the
array and it is but it still doesn't
have enough information to return the
results so we must check if the property
actually exists in the array just in
case there is a hole at this position in
this case a property exists so we can
finally return its value now if the
property didn't exist we would be back
in the situation from before where I
would have to look up prototype chain
which is very expensive and bad for
performance now this is the very best
case scenario for a holy array and it's
still one more operation compared to a
packed array and this is why in general
packed arrays are preferred over holy
arrays operations on packed arrays can
just be optimized in a much more
aggressive way than operations on holy
arrays for optimal performance you
should try and avoid creating holes
whenever you can so we looked at this
pyramid before with this list of
elements kinds there's smize doubles and
regular elements and we knew that we can
transition
downwards throughout this pyramid but
now we learned that it turns out there's
actually two flavors for each of these
elements kinds there's the packed
version and there's a Holi version and
not only can we transition downwards we
can also transition from left to right
we can go from packed to holy so instead
of two separate pyramids it's probably a
little bit easier to think of elements
kinds as a lattice and that is in fact
how v8 implements the system around
elements kinds and the transitions
between them more concretely it looks
something like this
so we have our smile double and regular
elements and each of those comes in two
flavors
there's the pact and the holy version
now these are the most common array
elements kinds but v8 distinguishes
about twenty different elements kinds
for other things like typed arrays as
well and you can only transition
downwards throughout this lattice it's
kind of like that pokemon blue tower
puzzle where all the tiles have like an
arrow drawn on the floor and when you
step on a tile you can only move in that
direction the same goes here you can
only follow the arrows throughout the
lattice which means you can never go
back up once a single floating-point
number is added to an array it is marked
as double even if it later consists of
Smiles only and similarly once you
create a hole in an array it has marked
as holy now in general more specific
elements kinds enable more fine-grained
optimizations the further down the
elements kindness in this lattice the
slower manipulations and operations on
that object might be so for optimal
performance it makes sense to needlessly
to avoid needlessly transitioning
between these elements kinds and stick
to the most specific elements kinds that
applies to your use case let's look at
an example for that for each unique
elements kind v8 can apply specific of
image optimizations when performing
operations on the array whenever you're
using for each for example v8 can
optimize this call based on this
knowledge about the elements kind we can
have one set of for each optimizations
specifically for packets my elements
another set of optimizations for packed
double elements and so on and over time
we can add more and more of these
optimizations so if you look at chrome
59 for example this
when we just shipped a new pipeline in
v8 we had ignition our new interpreter
and turbofan our new optimizing compiler
and at the time we didn't really do
anything special with this information
for for each so while we renew the
elements kinds of these arrays we didn't
specifically optimize any of these
elements kinds but by the time chrome 61
was released we had optimized for each
in turbofan for all packed elements
kinds and more recently in chrome 64 we
added support for the holy elements
kinds as well four for each specifically
so this is a pattern that you'll see
repeated over time over time we will add
more and more fine-grain and specific
optimizations for different elements
kinds for specific array functionality
so you could say the same thing about
rate of prototype dot map for example we
support all these different elements
kinds for map in chrome 64 as well same
goes for filter some every reduce reduce
right and then there's some other array
methods like find and find index and
these two are a little bit special if
you look them up in the spec you'll find
that these Street holes in erase a
little bit differently than all of the
other array methods because they turn
holes into explicit undefined values
which makes things a little bit
complicated for us and for that reason
we haven't yet been able to optimize a
holy double elements so far but like I
said before this is something that we're
working on and over time you can expect
to see more green in these lattices for
any given array method so very soon it
will look like this now let's look at
another example this piece of code
creates an array of length 3
but what values does the array contain
it just has three holes in it so the
array is sparse at this point so it gets
the element kind holy smile
holy is my elements because that's the
most specific possibility given the
currently available information now
let's assign a value to position zero in
the array well wait a minute that's a
string instead of a small integer so in
this case the elements kinds transitions
to holy elements now we add a value
to position one in the array and the
elements kinds remains unchanged in this
case and finally we sign another value
to the last position in the array now at
this point all three positions in the
array are filled so the array is packed
and no longer sparse however we cannot
transition to a more specific kind as
packed elements as we saw after we seen
earlier so unfortunately the elements
kind remains holy elements at this point
once an array is marked as holy it is
holy forever I believe that's how
sainthood works as well now in this
scenario a better solution is of course
to use an array literal instead if you
know all the values ahead of time then
why not just add them in an array
literal but if you don't know all the
values ahead of time you can still use a
technique that is similar you can start
off with an empty array or with an array
that contains some of the values that
you already know and then you can push
more values to it as you dynamically
compute them or get them from some
external source that way you avoid
creating holes in the array at any given
time and the array will never get marked
as holy this approach ensures that v8
optimizes any future operations on the
array to the best of its abilities life
is easier without poles JavaScript
engines can deal with packed arrays much
more efficiently in general if you need
to perform lots of operations on an
array try and avoid creating holes in it
and similarly you should avoid reading
beyond the length of the array because
there's nothing there anyway so for
example don't write your loops like this
this loop reads all the elements in the
array and then one more it only stops
when it finds an undefined or null
element so this also means that it would
only work for arrays that don't contain
undefined or no now this kind of pattern
is just as bad as hitting a hole it's a
different scenario but it's very similar
because in this case the bounds check
that we did before fails the check to
see if the property is present fails and
then we need to look up the prototype
chain just like before and as we've
learned that is very expensive so don't
do this and instead keep your loop
simple if you have to write out your own
loop you can do
do it the simple way you can keep track
of the index and keep iterating until
you hit the last element when the
collection you're looping over is
iterable which is the case for arrays
and node lists for example then that's
even better you can just use for off and
this is my favorite way of looping over
any kind of collection in JavaScript
because it's so simple now for arrays
specifically of course you can also use
array dot prototype out for each that
also works and the good news today is
that whether you want to use for each or
write your own for loop or use for off
performance-wise it doesn't matter
anymore which means you can just make
that decision and pick your favorite
without performance being a factor in
that decision I think that's pretty
great now avoid creating avoid reading
beyond the end of the array in summary
so doing so is just as bad as hitting a
hole now before we move on to some more
performance advice here's a fun facts
javascript has two zeros there's the
regular zero which is positive but
there's also a negative zero and
although these values are strictly equal
to each other
because of course why wouldn't they be
it turns out that they're actually
observably different in some cases and
object op is is an example of that
because they behave differently
it means javascript engines has have to
store these values separately as well in
different ways and the reason I'm
telling you this is because this has an
impact on elements kinds I mentioned
earlier that a piece of advice when it
comes to elements kind is to avoid
transitioning to a less specific
elements kind whenever you can and this
is actually harder than it seems for
example just adding minus 0 to an array
of small integers is enough to
transition it to packed double elements
any future operations on this array will
now be optimized in a completely
different way and they would be for
smiles specifically so that's just one
more reason to avoid negative 0 in
general unless of course you need to
explicitly differentiate between
negative and positive 0 in your code but
you probably don't now the same thing
goes for nan and infinity these values
are stored as a double
which means that adding a single lamp to
an array of smile elements transitions
it to double elements so if you're
planning on performing lots of
operations on an array of integers you
should consider normalizing the values
before you're adding them to the array
so normalize minus zero to positive zero
and block-man and infinity when you're
initializing the values this way the
array sticks to the packets my elements
kind and of course there's a one time
normalization cost involved there for
all the extra text that you do when
you're initializing the array but it can
be worth the later optimizations in fact
if you're doing lots of mathematical
operations on an array of numbers should
probably look into using type arrays
because v8 has specific elements guides
for those as well and they're kind of
optimized for this kind of thing in
general if you need to perform lots of
operations on an array try sticking to
an elements kind that's as specific as
possible so that v8 can optimize it as
much as possible some objects in
JavaScript especially in the Dom look
like arrays although there aren't proper
arrays it's possible to create array
like objects yourself which is what I'm
doing here this object has a length
property and it supports indexed element
access just like a real array but it
lacks array methods like for each on its
prototype it's still possible to call
these array methods on this object
though here we're calling the array for
each built-in on the array like object
and that works as expected however this
is going to be slower than calling array
than calling for each on a proper array
which is highly optimized in v8 so if
you plan on using array built-ins on
this object more than once
consider turning it into an actual array
beforehand so that v8 can optimize these
operations to the best of its abilities
and here we're using slice to do that so
of course there is a one-time cost of
doing the actual slice call but this
cost can be worth the later
optimizations especially if you plan on
performing lots of operations on the
array and a specific example of this is
the arguments object this is an array
like object so when you call array
built-in such as for each on it it works
but it won't be fully up to
that's the way it could be for a proper
airing so nowadays I think there is a
better solution to this in the form of
es2015 rest parameters they produce
proper arrays that can be used instead
of the array like arguments objects in a
very elegant way so nowadays I think
there is no good reason to use the
arguments object anymore
use rest parameters it will make your
code more elegant and more optimizable
in various JavaScript engines as well
this is not a real crocodile and it's
not gonna have the same performance as a
real crocodile the same thing goes for
arrays in general you should avoid array
like objects whenever possible and use
real arrays instead now after all this
talk about elements kinds you may be
wondering how you can identify the
elements kinds of a given array in your
code base maybe you're debugging a
performance issue or maybe you just want
to have a deeper understanding of what
I'm talking about well you can run you
can compile v8 from source in a debug
build and run the d8 binary d8 stands
for developer shell or debug build no
one on the v8 team really knows what it
stands for actually it's a mystery D but
what I do know is that you have to pass
in the allow native syntax flag doing so
enables access to some internal v8
functionality from within JavaScript
it's very powerful especially if you
combine this with a debug build of v8 so
entering that command opens up a wrapper
which is very similar to what you get if
you just type node on your command line
except this way we can run some code
directly in v8 so now it's time to write
some code first we create the array that
we want to test and then we call one of
those special v8 internal functions on
it in this case debug print and you see
how the name there starts with a
percentage sign yeah that's not actually
valid JavaScript and the reason why we
do this is because we don't want people
to use this in production it doesn't
make sense to use it in production and
by making it invalid javascript we kind
of force it on people that they cannot
use this in production this would only
work in this particular built of v8
anyway so doesn't make sense to try to
use it elsewhere now running this code
prints a lot of output
even more than what is shown here in the
slide but in this case what we're
looking for is the elements kind of the
array which is listed on this line the
elements kind is holy smile elements cow
now that cow does not refer to the
animal it stands for copy-on-write which
is yet another internal optimization but
don't worry about that for now we can
talk about it in another presentation or
just come talk to me later
let's recap what we've seen so far we've
explored what elements kinds are and how
they work and as a result we were able
to identify some practical tips that can
help us boost performance avoid creating
holes in arrays don't access array
indexes beyond the arrays length try to
keep the elements kind of your array as
specific as possible by sticking to a
single value type for each array avoid
using array like objects and when you
have to use them consider converting
them into proper arrays before
performing any expensive operations on
them now although this presentation
covered some v8 specific internals these
tips don't just apply to v8 other
JavaScript engines can benefit from them
as well and by following this advice I
guarantee you that your code is not
going to get slower in any of the other
engines in fact it will probably get
faster across the board now there is one
more thing that I quickly wanted to
mention we went to an example like this
before where we have an array and it has
some values in it and if you know the
values beforehand it makes sense to
hard-code them into an array literal
like this but things get more
interesting for larger arrays especially
if you don't know all the values
beforehand maybe you're computing the
values dynamically or you're fetching
them from some third party source or
whatever and if you know the length of
this array ahead of time especially if
the array is very large it makes sense
to pass it through the array constructor
like this and doing so ensures that
JavaScript engines can pre allocate
space for all the 9001 elements the
array will hold the downside is as we've
seen before that the array will be
marked as holy from the moment it's
created so there's some ups and some
downs here when using the array
constructor like this
javascript engines can pre allocate the
space that they need for the correct
number of needed elements behind the
scenes especially for large arrays this
might speed up the actual creation of
the array however the array is marked as
holy from the beginning so there's
potentially slower array operations on
the array compared to packed arrays it
depends on which you know what you want
to optimize the creation or the
operations of the array to avoid going
holy we discussed this pattern where you
start with an empty array and then as
you get more values you just push them
to the array now when you create an
array the JavaScript engine creates a
buffer in the backing store to hold all
this array elements and for an empty
array that we already initialize a
buffer of 16 elements in v8 to give it
some room to grow now when a new element
is added that doesn't fit in the buffer
anymore we have to create a new buffer
in the backing store and then copy over
all the elements from the old array
behind the scenes and this is an
expensive operation and this is called
reallocation now if you start off with
an empty array for example and then you
push 9001 items to it one by one then v8
will reallocate the buffer in the
backing store for a total of 16 times
which is not too bad but this number
grows as the array gets larger so
especially for large arrays you might
want to consider this starting from an
empty array and continuously pushing to
it ensures we never create any holes
which is good the array remains packed
and any future operations on the array
can be fully optimized but the downside
of continuously pushing to an array that
is continuously pushing to an array is
that behind the scenes engines need to
reallocate the space as the array grows
all the time and for a large race maybe
not 9001 elements may be millions of
elements this might slow down the actual
creation of the array so either you
choose to optimize the array creation
itself by using new array passing in the
length if you know it so that it can be
pre-allocated behind the scenes or you
choose to optimize the later operations
on the array in this case it makes sense
to avoid holy elements kinds and it's a
trade-off for sure and which of these
two you pick depends
on the use case that you have in your
specific code finally the last piece of
advice I'd like to give is to write
modern idiomatic JavaScript without
worrying about performance too much
because that way JavaScript engines can
make it fast for you
thank you
[Applause]
you